اسامه مواطن اللبناني مصاب بعدوى الكوليرا
من سكان بيروت ويبلغ من العمر 79 عاما
يرجح ان يكون قد اصيب بالكوليرا بعد تردده
على احد المطاعم في جنوب لبنان
النفس للاكل ما في جيعان بدي اكل
ما قدرناه
او الكهرباء عن معامل تكرير المياه
بالاضافه الى اختلاط المياه الجوفيه بمياه
الصرف الصحي اسباب ساهمت في انتشار
الكوليرا
بالماي ماء مستعمله
للاستعمال الشخصي للشرب البنيه التحتيه
عنه بصرف الصحي بمعظم المناطق منها كثير
منيحه ففي انتشار بس بشر انتشار الكبير
من منظمه الصحه العالميه ودول الاخرى كافر
فرنسا والهند ستوزع بطريقه مدروسه للحد من
انتشار العدوى
اول شيء البار اللي في منصابه اللي قلنا
فيها هي بنيه عكار وارسال اول ناس هياخذوه
حكماء ممرضات مختبر
صليب احمر اسعافات الخط الثاني